[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous je pense que
le meilleur ami de merci c'est beaucoup
donc je remercie vivement et
chaleureusement les personnes qui ont eu
la gentillesse de me permettre justement
cette cette séquence de partage ce que
j'ai envie de partager avec vous je les
ai intitulé le courage d'être heureux et
je vais vous présenter l'offre
l'histoire d'un jeune homme qui
s'appelle est né le 4 11 1998 deux mois
avant sa naissance il ya le médecin qui
annonce à son papa que il fait partie
des bébés qui peuvent mourir deux jours
avant ou deux jours après la naissance
et qu'il fallait qu'ils taisent cette
information pour sa maman comme ça il va
accoucher de façon normale
donc ils accouchent deux mois plus tard
la maman accouche et c'est moi qui me
vient au monde ne va pas été lésés ils
étaient en train d'attendre que la même
heure parce que finalement on lui a dit
qu'il allait mourir des joueurs avant
durable sauf que il est né avec un an
stéphane hessel occipital au niveau du
cerveau 35 cm remplis de liquide céphalo
rachidien
il fallait qu'il fasse la première
opération à deux jours de sa naissance
ok on fait la première opération
peut-être qu'il va mourir deux jours
plus tard donc il est pas mort deux
jours plus tard donc il faut après la
après la première opération il faut
qu'ils reviennent voir le médecin au cas
où il ya contrôle et donc tilt la
deuxième opération c'est une semaine
après sa naissance puis la troisième
opération ces deux semaines après sa
naissance et la quatrième opération un
mois après la naissance puis la 5e puis
la 6e puis la 7e puis la huitième et on
attendait qu'il meurt donc finalement la
huitième la 9e la 10e à la 11e
la onzième il est un peu spécial parce
qu'elle était à craindre ouvert et la
duré cinq heures
enfin ouvert opération
et donc un an plus tard il fallait aussi
l'emmener à l'hôpital necker à paris
pour qu'il soit retiré nos ce ticket
n'est pas encore mort le gamin se dit
peut-être que quand il va faire un an et
deux mois et davantage comme si les
médecins qui sont hyper scientifique
dans la méthode pour décrypter les
choses on s'attendait à ce qu'ils
meurent donc un an et demi plus tard pas
encore donc deux ans il fallait qu'il
aille dans une petite école donc ils ont
commencé l'école après peut-être qu'il
va faire le cp tient là où il arrive en
quelqu'un qui allait mourir des jours
avant ou 12 jours après il est au cp
après c'est un de ces quatre après le
collège après le lycée et cette année il
vient de voir son baccalauréat il est
pas encore mort il est ici présents dans
la salle cet enfant donc j'avais envie
de partager avec vous son histoire pour
plusieurs raisons parce que tout au long
de ce parcours c'est un enseignement
riche en émotions et donc j'ai appelé
cette intervention le courage d'être
heureux qui pour moi elle est synonyme
avec le courage de vivre et j'ai envie
de partager avec vous alors voilà il est
là quand il a eu son baccalauréat
son médecin traitant qui m'annonçait
qu'il allait mourir donc il est encore
là je pense qu'il vivra encore les 100
prochaines années
si c'est pas au physique mais en tous
les cas dans nos coeurs alors qu'est ce
que nous avons appris dans ce parcours
qui nous permet de vivre et de continuer
à vivre et d'espérer que demain sera
meilleur
alors beaucoup de choses j'ai envie de
les partager j'appelais des secrets du
bonheur et le courage de vie de vivre
alors qu'un il nous a appris à être et à
rester jeune
cette jeunesse qui n'est pas une période
de la vie sa dette à d'esprit en effet
de volonté qualité d'imagination il nous
a appris à ne jamais poser la question
comprendre pourquoi parce que si on
s'était posé la question pourquoi on
allait être dans une situation qui est
pourquoi ça vous arrive qu est-ce qu on
m'a fait au bon dieu mais pourquoi nous
est pas d eau
alors que la question qu'on avait eu la
chance d'avoir et de recevoir comme un
don c'est et comment
comment l'accompagner pour qu'ils
puissent grandir comme on continue à
l'aimer comment continuer à lui
permettre de grandir et de vivre et
d'apprécier la vie et aujourd'hui il
fait de la musique il fait beaucoup de
choses et c est donc il ya deux types de
personnes on appris qu'il ya ce qui pose
la question pourquoi cela il l'attend ce
père aimant ou désespérément de
comprendre peut-être qu'ils
entreprennent quelque chose mais des
fois il n'entreprenne rien il ce qui
vaut poser la question pourquoi pas et
c'est cela qu'ils font un pas qu'on ne
s'est pas fait en avant il avance et
progresse il continue à s'émerveiller
ils sont heureux joyeux plaisant ils
apprennent que la vie c'est à la fois
des eaux
mais c'est aussi surtout des bas et
c'est vouloir vivre dans l'éternité de
cette jouvence joie plaisir avec un gros
sourire tous les jours c'est juste à
leurs illusions qui ne mène pas à vivre
de façon grande et de façon durable la
deuxième enseignement qu'on a appris ce
qu'est ce que tu tiens il te retiens si
tu tiens à l'argent il va te relire tu
resterait immobile qui ne progressera
pas et donc on s'est rendu compte que ce
qui nous tenait beaucoup c'était notre
ego et qu'il fallait se vider de soi
même pour se remplir de la beauté du
vivant quand j'ai dit du vivant c'est à
dire je pèse mon mot c'est à dire la
beauté du vivant c'est à dire tout ce
qui vit peut nous apporter du plaisir de
la joie de l'immensité de la grandeur et
et du bonheur on le voit quand on aime
des gens de façon inconditionnelle de
façon circonscrite déconnecté par
rapport à une réciprocité
on est tout simplement heureux joyeux et
des fois on sourit on sait même pas
pourquoi c'est parce que quelque part on
a conscientisé comme le disait mona lisa
ils ont la conscientisation faire le
bien fait du bien mon père m'a appris
également contre 6 mois qu'il était venu
sur la planète terre terre et sud dans
cette dimension que toutes les raisons
du désespoir peuvent être là toutes les
pubs et là deux choses qu'il peut vous
permet de trouver un salut la fois est
la bonne parole
la fois est la bonne oeuvre
la fois et tout ce qui est bien tout ce
qui est bien quand on le fait on fait du
bien et ça fait aussi du bien on a
appris que pour être heureux
j'aime beaucoup ça m'a beaucoup inspiré
la présentation d'avant qui était
beaucoup investissent dans l'être dans
la voir plus tôt et on oublie qu'il faut
investir dans l'être avec ses moyens
mais dans s'était rendu compte qu'il
savait il s'agissait pas de lui acheter
une montre se savait absolument à rien
il fallait offrir le temps il est comme
une montre à la limite
elles peuvent nous indiquer le temps
mais nous on avait besoin de lui offrir
le temps et de panda de sens que s'il a
rempli par la vie s'il a rempli par le
malheur à la limite ils ne savent
absolument pas grand chose ça mérite
même pas qu'on y soit dans cette
dimension pour pouvoir la mener à bien
et donc parmi des choses qu'on a aussi
apprise c'est comment est ce qu'on peut
apprendre à dire merci la merci à qui à
quoi
merci à tous à tous partout merci comme
le dit jean jacques d'ormesson
merci aux roses merci aux épines m'a
fait aux éléphants merci à la lumière
dans un chemin quand on progresse vers
eux vers ce chemin de bonheur ou de paix
intérieure ou de joie je pense qu'il ya
des choses qui nous interpellent
il ya ceux qui vont se poser des
questions juste les ce qui pousse juste
des questions et toute la beauté de
l'histoire fait de pouvoir changer de
paradigme on peut chercher juste des
réponses on peut mener une vie
courageuse amené à trouver des réponses
justes
il s'agit in fine et de mener le combat
juste dans sa vie et pas juste un combat
le combat juste c'est ce combat pour
lequel on est prêt à vivre
il ya consacré une partition
d'intelligence de son intensité de son
amour de sa gratitude de sa fierté de
son honneur pour pouvoir honorer
justement toute cette cette vie qui nous
est offerte
j'ai appris également qu'il faut dire
merci à la vie qu'il faut la regarder
avec souris avec bienveillance
quand on reçoit des fois un tsunami de
souffrance de peine
on reçoit en même temps un tsunami de
paix et de bonheur quand on pose la
question comment est-ce qu'on va
s'améliorer comment est-ce qu'on va
progresser avec
nous arrive il ne peut pas y avoir de
situation désespérante continue durable
et avis c'est impossible quand le
médecin nous disait qu' il allait mourir
je le regarder droit dans les yeux
j'avais eu la chance de de fait
rationnel spirituel et mon père là pour
me dis à la limite qui viennent qu'il
parte
après tout c'est juste une épreuve de
vie si tu peux la vivre pleinement
chaque instant que dieu fait est un
instant qu'il faut vivre pleinement
j'ai également croisé une dame qui avait
pratiquement le même la même situation
que nous et il me parlait de sa fille
une fille qui avait deux ans et demi
condamné aussi à mourir sauf que sela
est morte deux ans après et il avait au
même pas un enfant de 4 ans cet enfant
de 4 ans savez quand on reçoit quand le
médecin vous dit vous allez certainement
avoir un enfant qui va mourir
c'est pratiquement un tsunami de malheur
vous recevez pratiquement désespérance
total la peine la souffrance ou croyez
vous êtes unique à recevoir tout ça et
cette dame ne me parlait de son histoire
quand elle a lancé cela sans son fils
son fils de 4 ans il a commencé à
pleurer
bien sûr la maman pleurer toutes les
larmes de sa vie le pape a aussi bien un
moment donné l'enfant de 4 ans il s'est
essuyé le visage il lui dit alors
l'anniversaire de ma soeur on le fait ou
pas et la maman elle était un peu
abasourdi c'est pas possible on ne peut
pas imaginer un instant où on peut
parler de fêter un anniversaire alors
que nous avons quelqu'un qui est mort ou
là qui va mourir et 7,7 confort gaza
même endroit dont lui et lui dit maman
là ici maintenant il n'est pas morte
ici maintenant il n'est pas encore morte
et donc c'est de cette conscientisation
du temps présent
c'est ici et maintenant que le voleur se
cherche ce n'est pas demain
beaucoup de gens cherchent le bonheur il
oublie de vivre alors que lui il est
dans le chemin
c'est de pouvoir vivre la vie le secret
de la vie c'est un de se sentir aimé
parce qu'on aime aussi de se sentir aimé
par la diversité des créations qui
assure cette planète et qui avant ce
monde et qui a dans ce conte semences
c'est la capacité de se remplir de
gratitude c'est aussi et surtout je
pense courage de vivre c'est
d'entreprendre pour se surprendre et
pour le reste que apprendre à être
porter en soi de ce bonheur le bonheur
il faut juste le porter ne serait ce que
pour donner l'exemple
je pense qu'avec nos enfants avec tous
ceux qu'on croise il faut être heureux
ne serait ce que pour donner l'exemple
il faut être heureux
ne serait ce que pour les gens puissent
identifier que ça existe dans le mot
désespoir
j'aime beaucoup le diviser en deux
désespoir il est dit vise à bhl c'est
des espoirs et donc si on l'entend comme
étant la pluralité des espoirs possibles
on peut investir le champ du futur et on
peut entreprendre c'est comme le moins
possible si on entend comme étant écrit
en français
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
peut être justement dans l'impossibilité
mais si on entend en anglais ou aussi
longtemps en deux temps impossible vous
est possible
vous êtes cette possibilité ou là en
anglais car il faut faire iam possible
et vous allez être dans cette pluralité
de possibilités on posait la question à
bout de bush qui es tu on ce courage de
vie parce qu'il a entrepris un chemin à
la fois politique de défense d'une cause
qui était juste venu poser la question
qui est tué sa réponse était un n'diaye
d'eads au feeder il est régi le moutier
gibier d'eau web de la poste dès que je
l'aï su nous at il dit à l'afp
orabi accès firmine richard le courage
de vie on sait être porteur de sens
porteur d'un message de paix d'espoir
pour soi pour la communauté pour les
autres pour la vie c'est s'identifier
comme étant porteur d'un message qui est
celui d'être au minimum comme la lune la
lune et les sympathiques
elle est claire elle ne brille pas d
étoile brille mais la lune éclaire si on
se remplit de cette lumière qu'il ya en
chacun ici on se vide de notre ego de
cette volonté d'avoir et ne pas être
beaucoup d'argent on l'a où on l'a en
l'argent mais n'ont pas de valeur
beaucoup l'histoire de quelqu'un qui
avouent qu'ils aient une maison dans
laquelle il habite il ya quelqu'un
d'autre qui a plusieurs maisons ils
habitent en lui et donc ce sont ces egos
et de peurs ses angoisses cette capacité
de sortir de soin de se dissocier de
soin de se distancer par rapport à ces
peurs celle qui nous permet de nous
élever d'ailleurs les enfants commencent
que les appels à l'école les élèves
parce qu'il s'élève
ils brandissent je pense que le propre
de ce courage de vivre cette courage de
grandir c'est de pouvoir vivre dans
l'instant présent jour que dieu fait
avec bienveillance avec respect même
quand il faut se disputer il faut se
disputer avec élégance et avec
bienveillance
bien sûr est ce que le monde est porteur
de message que de paix je pense que nous
vivons dans un monde qui est plein de
mutation et de changements auxquels
personne ne peut échapper les
contraintes sont plurielles politique
économique sociale culturelle
technologique sécuritaire démographique
légales sociales sociétales bref elles
sont de toutes natures on investit de
plus en plus de champ de l'extériorité
au détriment de l'intériorité
on veut paraître alors qu' il est plus
simple d'être on veut avoir et on oublie
d'être il ya un philosophe qui s'appelle
l'instant qui avait théorisé avait créé
un livre sur lang son problème langue
bien sûr avec un grand f l'homme sans
problème c'est là où on a aussi dit si
on arrive à assouvir toutes les quatre
prises tous les sons vie peut-être qu'on
serait heureux et finalement même dans
des villes où tout est permis et las
vegas par exemple il ya encore des gens
qui sont malheureux est heureux c'est
ici et maintenant est heureux c'est
pouvoir ressentir la tendresse de coeur
d'une maman la splendeur de ce rire d'un
papa il sait aussi la beauté du geste
d'un enfant c'est juste admirer c'est
juste pouvoir s'émerveiller quand je
disais tout à l'heure que la jeunesse
n'est pas une période de la vie que
c'était un état d'esprit à nous faites
volonté j'avais envie de vous dire aussi
clients
quand on devient vieux c'est peut-être
canton 3 quand on a vécu plusieurs
années sur cette planète
lors de mon point de vue on devient
vieux comptes en a déserté son idéal
quand on n'a plus d'objectif quant à
l'implication quand on cesse de
s'émerveiller
quand le wahoo on l'appelait on se
souvient de certaines personnes qui à 24
ans on leur pose la question qu'est ce
qui vous émerveille ils sont fades terne
pour elle avait terminé ils ont fait le
tour de la question
ils sont remplis de la malheur de
l'humanité de tous les malheurs de
l'humanité
il n'entre en priant lourd l'on peut
rencontrer des gens à 80 ans qui sont
plein de vie qui vous présente les
projets sur les trente prochaines années
il sent plein de vivacité la clé la
règle d'or c'est il se pose la question
pourquoi pas ils sont dans ce que
j'appelle le lifelong learning
j'ai vu de loin 5 minutes je crois que
c'était cinq minutes j'ai multiplié par
100 et donc je disais que quand on
arrive à un moment donné à être
consciente de l'état dans lequel en est
à être éveillé le monde dans lequel on
est sur tout ce monde digital où on est
ultra connectés sur tout et partout et
surtout on a les informations sur tout
et sur tout et partout et on n'est
malheureusement pas connecté à nous
mêmes
cet exercice introspectif qui nous
permettent de poser des questions sur
qu'est-ce que je veux qu est ce que je
suis prêt à faire de quoi suis fier de
mon passé de mon avenir
est-ce que qu'est-ce que je suis prêt à
faire pour avoir ce que j'ai envie
d'avoir
qu'est ce que je suis prêt à renoncer
pour être ce que j'ai envie d'être dans
cette possibilité que nous avons jeudi
un avocat a dit dos est ce que nous
voulons être un ou pour être plusieurs
nous voulons être plusieurs dans la
façon de se révéler à nous mêmes de
l'aef lenglen et c'est une manière aussi
de mon point de vue d'être dense est à
la fois dans cette quête vers le bonheur
ouvert
la sagesse ou vers la sérénité et la
voix la volupté la féliciter
l'émerveillement mais elle passe par sa
capacité par la capacité de chacun à
apprendre mais aussi à désapprendre et à
réapprendre et à entreprendre et à
comprendre avant de vouloir être compris
et à écouter avant de vouloir et écouter
identifié cette cause pour laquelle il
est prêt à vivre et à mourir une cause
qui nous permet à un moment donné non
pas de renoncer à ce que nous sommes ou
à ce que nous avons été longtemps le cas
de tracer un chemin pour tous ceux qui
vont venir après louer qui vont porter
la voix vers vers vos là pour que
l'ordre
j'ai envie de dire à vous tous ici
présents et tous ceux qui vont nous
écouter à travers la planète
je ne sais pas si ça va être traduit
dans tous les cas j'aime beaucoup cette
phrase qui dit want is enough au thorax
factuel virer illico la scène sa propre
chaîne ou un scénario fille betty carter
si le kawa qui vaut à de nouveaux chocs
qui le réclame à deux semaines la
belgique dizaine l'île banane one
dessous a dit fatou racines ma fac
elvira et ricardo mata mognard d'haruna
brahmanes want to fuck you be la farine
fait qu'il vit 9,6 pour l'italie ce
match ne fait pas là merci beaucoup